dass man ihn so anzünden kann sehen wir
die explosion ist viel viel viel größer
als wir noch mal einem normalen kredit
locker zwei oder dreimal so groß wie ich
meine lieben freundin herzlich
willkommen zu minecraft fakes parteien
und 40 die letzte folge die
vorproduzierte von meinem urlaub das
heißt in der nächsten folge wird wieder
das geheimnisvolle geräusche ankommen
und auch aufgelöst werden und was ich
immer vor dem effekt sagen muss e mail
ihr könnt mir mail können effects per
mail an konkret china.com zu senden und
ich kann nicht dafür garantieren dass
die sachen die ich euch hier vorstellen
ich schon in irgend einem anderen video
vorgekommen sind und ich kann euch dafür
garantieren dass eventuell alles hier
vor noch nicht willst also ich möchte
euch einfach coole sachen vorstellen die
ich noch nicht kannte die ich sehr cool
finde und möchte ich einfach daran
teilhaben ich würze angefangen mit dem
ersten effekt und zwar gibt es geladene
creeper die kennt ihr wahrscheinlich und
die kann man auch spawnen und zwar nicht
mit spore sondern dafür muss man diesen
befehl eingeben
/ also schrägstrich zusammen das heißt
immer irgendwas spawnen leerzeichen
creeper leerzeichen fälle leerzeichen
welle leerzeichen bälle mehr zeichen
powered also dass er geladen ist
doppelpunkt ein sondern die geschwungene
klammer wieder zu so das muss ich mal
ganz kurz machen dafür macht man einfach
auf einfach so zac und jetzt haben sie
einen geladenen creeper und ihr seht
schon hin was unterscheidet in diesen
geladenen kleber von dem anderen creeper
ihr seht schon da ist drum rum wenn ich
mal ganz kurz meinen respekt ändere dann
seht ihr das wahrscheinlich noch besser
dass er geladen ist und zwar ist das
ganze sonne sonne sonne glitzert es soll
halt sondern so ein blitz darstellt wenn
ich den jetzt beispielsweise ich immer
mal wieder sex speckmann das resort pack
ist echt hier ein bisschen eklig welches
beispielsweise angreife okay ich bin im
trade off mode ich mache mir einfach mit
dem feuerzeug das haben wir auch vom
board folgen gelernt dass man ihn so
anzünden kann
sehen wir die explosion ist viel viel
viel größer als bei normal einem
normalen überdies locker zwei oder drei
mal so groß und der kripo soll quasi
seinen geladenen zustand darstellt ist
voller power
es war genauso wie normaler creeper also
von einer von einer haltbarkeit von
einer lebensdauer blabla also ihr könnt
braucht genauso lange um den zu töten
allerdings macht erhalten viel viel
größeres loch und das einfach so
eingeladen aktiv setzt sich auch noch
die rolle an
es ist einfach so ein geladener creeper
und ich liebe das einfach dass das
minecraft mittlerweile so richtig krasse
mops hinzugefügt hat auch sowie den
ender drachen so richtig krasse mops und
ja ich wollte ja wieder zeigen wie man
den spot kann und dann könnt ihr damit
selbst warum spielen und das perfekt
nummer eins kommen wir zurecht nummer
zwei und zwar sind tintenfische die
einzigen passiven mops neben
fledermäusen die keine kinder bekommen
können
also man kann tintenfische nicht
irgendwie paaren oder irgendwie sowas
die treten einfach auf und normalerweise
habe ich euch auch mal gezeigt man kann
einfach wenn man ein tier spawn mit dem
spawn auch auf das gleiche tier also mit
dem wenn ich ein schwein hat mache ich
mit dem sport von schweinen mache ich
rechtsklick auf ein schwein und ich
kriegen schweine baby bei einem
tintenfisch einig da richtig drauf
machen dann kommt einfach noch neuer
tintenfisch und da kommt auch noch ein
neuer tintenfisch und rückfahrt auf
quasi und die können keine kinder
bekommen sieht sehr cool aus dass sie
hier in verschiedenen farben schwimmer
das ein sehr sehr viele tage also könnt
keine kinder bekommen sie jetzt wirklich
aus lodz bezeichnet den krieg als being
crazy like 3 ließ zu deutsch erst
knusprig knackig die trockene blätter
dennoch werden krippen artworks immer
als pelt sich dargestellt also wenn ich
hatte hier noch mal aufgeschrieben
immer wenn man wenn ich irgendwelche
bilder von krieg den sie gemalt sind
sind die zwar wunderschön aber es ist
alles falsch dargestellt weil eintritt
ist wie notch sagt richtig hart und
knusprig sowie in die chips oder sowie
trockene blätter alles mögliche und das
leben wir auch hier dass da kein
bisschen pelz oder so dran ist er sieht
vielleicht manchen texmex auch so aus
aber hier hat er auch seinen gehäuteten
rücken die sonne idex oder irgendwie
sowas also er soll hart sein und nicht
so wie er in adwords die ich euch jetzt
mal eine blende die wird ja immer so ein
bisschen pelt sich kuschelig dargestellt
so soll er gar nicht sein und so möchte
natürlich dass er so dargestellt also
das ganze bild vom krieg zerstört wird
also das ist ein kleiner fun fact noch
schmollt eigentlich dass der körper
nämlich so crunchy ist sowie irgendwie
trockene blätter und nicht so hält sich
so wia ma networks dargestellt wird
weckt nummer 4 wieder was mit hinten
fischen zu tun und zwar habe ich schon
sonntag
und ich kann euch auch gleich mal die
hit boxes anmachen und zwar kann man
tintenfische nicht über die zehn tage
töten genauso wie gas wenn man gas
angreifen mit einem pfeil oder wenn man
denen so auf die tentakel schlägt kann
man ja auch nicht angreifen und hier
auch nicht also ich hab ich das mal
zeigen die sind hier alle graz und
bisschen hyperaktiv wenn ich hier zum
beispiel mal auf die tentakel schlage
seht ihr da passiert nichts ich musste
mich schon auf den kopf schlagen damit
er ihnen stirbt oder so hier auch
nochmal da zackig schlag auf die
tentakel nix passiert das sieht nämlich
wieder an den hit boxen was in der
letzten folge gelernt haben hier sehen
wie die hit box in diesem relativ blass
und zwar ja bla bla die schwimm und die
hip hops ist nur in den kopf rum und
nicht hier unten rum
genau das gleiche sehen wir solch man
gas von ich glaube ich baue mir eben
genau das gleiche sehen wir wenn ich
ihren gas bauen würde und zwar da ist
der gast und die hit box ist nur mein
kopf rum das heißt wenn ich ihn schlage
passiert nichts ich muss ihn schon da
oben einschlagen damit da irgendwas
passiert hier liegen noch ein paar teams
blabla und es ist halt wirklich so man
kann gas und hin was ist das da hinten
achter sind hit box es sogar um die
erfahrungsgemäß kommen sascha kohlmann
kann gas und tentakel fischer wollte
seine tadeusz nicht über die tentakel
töten sondern man muss wirklich indie
hit bock schlagen auf den kopf schlagen
bei dem gas und gas ist ja quasi
wirklich nur ein überdimensionaler
tintenfisch und natürlich auch sagen das
war's mit der heutigen folge es war so
ein tintenfisch special irgendwie oder
geladene kripo fand ich auch sehr sehr
geil die knospen und dann will ich sagen
es euch gefallen hat zeigt mit einer
bewertung text kennt ihn konkret
china.com schreiben
ich hoffe dass ganz viele geräusche
erraten
was ähnlich in der nächsten folge wieder
kommt also ich hoffe dass geräusche
raten was vor vier folgen kamen und dann
könnt ihr jetzt mal die kommentare
schreiben das in der nächsten folge
eventuell nochmal zeigen und dann will
ich sagen ich wünsche ihm auch schon das
nächste folge ist dann wieder mit dem
ganges von geräusch und tue also bevor
das komische ende egal